digamos que alguien es dueño de una
tienda de mascotas así que esta tienda
es muy peculiar pero es de hecho que soy
poco común en donde solo va a haber tres
tipos de animales ok entonces por un
lado sabemos que tiene gatos y al número
de gatos la vamos a denotar con la letra
g muy bien también vamos a vamos a tener
que esta tienda tiene perros perros y al
número de perros pues también vamos a
denotar lo ahora con la letra p y además
esta tiene esta tienda tiene osos ok por
eso es que es bastante peculiar esta
tienda y bueno platicando con el dueño
quizás estábamos tomándonos un cafecito
qué sé yo nos dice que tiene que el
número de gatos pues vamos a ponerlo con
el mismo color que el número de gatos es
muy es mayor que el número de perros y
que también tiene más perros que osos y
eso eso está bien porque porque sería
muy raro que tenga más osos que
cualquier otro de estos animales ok
entonces vas
en esto nos preguntan cuál de las
siguientes dos expresiones es mayor si
osos entre la suma de gatos con perros y
osos o bien un tercio muy bien entonces
te invito a que pases un poco el vídeo y
tú mismo razones cuál crees que sería la
respuesta puede ser que esta expresión
sea más chica que un tercio puede ser
también que sea más grande o puede que
sean iguales o definitivamente con esta
información que nos dan no podemos
saberlo entonces sí sí ya lo pensaste
vamos a continuar y veamos que realmente
esta expresión de aquí es muy importante
porque el estoque es el número de osos
dividido entre el número de gatos más el
número de perros el número de perros más
el número de osos pues es la proporción
o la fracción que hay de osos
respecto a todos los animales si sumamos
estas tres estamos diciendo todos los
gatos más los perros más los osos
el número total de animales que hay y si
aquí estamos tomando solo los osos
estamos diciendo cree qué fracción qué
fracción de osos hay en la tienda
entonces la fracción de osos muy bien
entonces
la pregunta es que si este número es más
grande menor o igual que un tercio puede
que no podamos decir entonces voy a dar
varios argumentos en a lo largo de los
siguientes vídeos hay muchas formas de
ver esto y en este vídeo voy a hacer una
forma visual ok entonces voy a pegar
digamos una es que me está digamos que
tengo este es que me está muy bien y
entonces digamos que este cuadrado
representa todos los animales y qué pasa
si la proporción de osos es más grande
que un tercio déjenme ponerlo así qué
pasa si la proporción es más grande que
un tercio entonces digamos que estas
líneas son un tercio y ahora los osos
digamos abarcan un poco más digamos que
los osos abarcan toda esta toda esta
fracción muy bien entonces sabemos por
lo que nos dice el dueño que hay más
perros que osos entonces la proporción
de perros tienen que pasar de
tercio entonces si esto era un poco más
de un tercio esto también va a ser
todavía más
digamos que abarca todo esto muy bien y
ahora bien nos dice también el dueño que
hay más gatos que perros pero que creen
aquí ya nos queda algo más chico que un
tercio entonces vamos a tener digamos
toda esta región y pues resulta que ya
nos pasamos entonces esto no puede ser
posible no puede ser posible muy bien
vamos a ver entonces otra forma que
puedes que puedes verlos digamos si la
proporción de osos es más grande que un
tercio quiere decir que entre gatos y
perros
tengo que la proporción entre gatos y
perros pues debe ser más debe ser más
chico que dos tercios entonces alguno
tiene que ser más chico que un tercio y
eso no puede ser posible por esta
relación verdad entonces vamos a ver qué
pasa en el caso en que fueran iguales
pegamos otro de estos qué pasa si la
proporción es igual a un tercio
vamos a ver qué pasa si la proporción es
igual a un tercio igual a un tercio
entonces aquí sobre esta línea encima
mos la proporción que hay de osos
encima mos la proporción que hay de osos
y ahora nos dicen que hay más perros que
osos entonces la fracción de los de los
perros como no como debe ser más grande
que un tercio quizás ande por acá
quizás ande hasta acá y tenemos
exactamente ahora el mismo problema que
teníamos anteriormente con cuando yo
intento poner aquí los gatos pues en
realidad debe ser algo más grande que
los perros y los perros se pasan de un
tercio y aquí ya tengo menos que un
tercio entonces nuevamente en este caso
no es posible no va a ser posible este
caso ahora vamos a ver el último porque
también podría ser que ninguno y
entonces estemos llegando a alguna
contradicción pero bueno vamos a ver que
en este caso por ejemplo si si la
proporción de osos es más chico que un
tercio digamos algo así
algo así no se podríamos tener que la
proporción de perros pues puede hacer
exactamente un tercio no algo así
puede ser que sea algo así y que la
proporción de gatos sea pues este este
restante no digamos este restante y
entonces este sí fue un caso compatible
si pudimos hacer que digamos poner a las
tres proporciones en este en este caso
en donde es más chico que un tercio ok
entonces en este caso si pudimos si es
creíble verdad otra vez esta es la
proporción de gatos que hay entre todos
los animales es decir entre esta suma
y acá ponemos la proporción de perros
que hay entre todos los animales y
finalmente ponemos la proporción que hay
de osos ching voy a ponerlo
con el color adecuado de osos respecto a
todos los animales y esto sí fue creíble
verdad de hecho si pudimos hacer que
esta expresión sea menor que un tercio y
este argumento visual con este árbol con
este argumento puedes darte cuenta que
la expresión tiene que ser menor a un
tercio entonces en el siguiente vídeo
daré argumentos analíticos que no
necesitan de dibujos para demostrar que
en efecto tiene que ser menor que un
tercio